the fact that he's out out
and then i'm on the sidelines and i hear
hey 17 said he wants to go back in
look you might think that's a normal
thing in this game
maybe it was 10 years ago but you just
see less and less of that happening i
think there's
more of a
oh you know doc doesn't think i can go
here maybe i should
sit sit out the rest of the game but 17
is built different
aaron rodgers talking about devonta
adams who seemed to be out yesterday
with an ankle injury and he was trying
to loosen up his hamstrings and it
looked like he wasn't going to be back
in he came back in he scored the go
ahead touchdown for the green bay
packers who moved to seven and two and
and uh
and and tortured the guy who had 99 000
wagered on the packers on the money line
bet wow at odds of minus 1100 to only
win 9 000
that
whatever
you went and obviously it's nine
thousand it's not worth the three hours
of hell
that that person had to go through
thinking that the 99 000 was going away
and never coming back and i spoke to
marquez valdez scandal had a great game
career high 149 receiving yards had a
long catch and run for a touchdown
earlier in the game from aaron rodgers
there's been this constant problem with
the packers at home this year they don't
have fans they don't have energy coach
matt lafleur mentioned to reporters
after the game valdez scanlan said hey
it's on us as players to muster it but
he acknowledged to me yeah early on they
just didn't have it if you watch the
game you could see it it happened
against the vikings and they lost it
happened against the lions and they
finally found a way to turn it on right
the only team it didn't happen against
was the falcons so in three of their
four home games the packers have come
out flat
and sluggish
and i think a lot of it has to do with
the fact that there's no fans in the
stands there chris well yeah i mean is
it certainly a great advantage up there
of their fans that you know setting is
always special that way
i think the other thing is too i mean
you know i don't want to be a jerk or
anything but just hey yeah they're seven
and two but like we've discussed like
we've heard coach dungey in a few clips
here today
it's just an underwhelming seven and two
and you know i don't want to be that way
you know i love aaron rodgers and green
bay and i root for them that way but
yeah they're just
there's not
any area of their team that's really
dominant like really dominant except for
12 and 17. that's the one area where you
can go no they're dominant and if you
let them one-on-one they're going to
beat you that's kind of where you know
they went into a lull yesterday with the
game 17-10 big pass play to devonte
adams he fumbles right sets up the short
field jacksonville 17 all and then
rogers throws an interception
uh you know either the next drive or two
drives later you know as they're down to
midfield and all of a sudden you're
going whoa watch out let alone they've
already let a punt return happen and the
jacksonville jaguars are running the
ball between the tackles almost at will
all day long so that's where it's weird
with green bay but when 12 and 17 are
out there they always got a chance
i asked about this scaling how much
grief jk scott was going to get for that
attempt to tackle
keelan oh man
yeah yeah
and uh he said none because he's paid to
punt the ball he's not paid to make a
good answer that's a good teammate very
good teammate
uh i i spoke to tuatanga viloa as well
and that was a challenge because we're
on the air
as i got the call because so many late
games yesterday i wanted to try to talk
to some of the guys who played in the
bigger games of the day and all due
respect to the 10 teams that played at
one o'clock for the most part
not not a great slate of early games
yesterday it's still football it's still
on tv so we watch it but uh tua tua
said to me that
the nfl isn't as hard as he thought it
was going to be not that it isn't hard
but he expected a lot more different
looks
and and this is a testament to brian
flores
tuatonga by loa got to the point where
he was confident in his abilities and
believed he belonged at the nfl level
because of practice because the
practices are so challenging that the
games
in comparison
you know are easy for him and he that's
where he got to the point against a good
scout team defense to get to the point
where he he feels like he can do it yeah
and uh you know i think he's going to
see more looks as he creates more film
that defensive coordinators can break
down once people get an understanding of
what he's doing why he's doing it but
he's very upbeat very optimistic very
just just a great great kid and you want
nothing but the best for him and you
know it was one year to the day since he
suffered the broken hip at alabama that
ended his college career and i asked him
about the the hits he's taken so far at
the nfl level and he said uh i i've i've
already taken enough i'm i'm fine i
don't want any more but he understands
that no matter what he does that's going
to be part of the game well he's so easy
to root for he's got such a great smile
charisma everything like that saw the
talent again yesterday
you know again saw a few help you know
throws in the pocket where i just oh wow
that looked good i mean the way he can
get the ball out of his hand and kind of
dance his feet and around it is special
that way it is and you know to the point
too mike where hey he's being coached
well he's being coached well and brian
flores coming from new england they're
not into like oh we want practice to be
perfect and we want tom brady to be 27
for 27 and the ball never hits the
ground no they don't they don't play
that you know that's where i think a lot
of teams mess up no they do they make
life hard i remember working in new
england we'd have practices some on a
friday sometimes and be like man
brady's like barely above 50 percent you
know and it wasn't that he was doing bad
but they were challenging him they
weren't just gonna give it like hey oh
you feel good you threw the ball
complete oh yeah we're good sunday we're
gonna win definitely practice was so
great they don't create that false
narrative it's always
challenge work wait what if they did
this against that even though we don't
like it we don't expect it but what if
and that's where flores is awesome let
alone he was coached by nick saban in
college so yeah he's ready and they got
a nice formula working and everything
there too but the dolphins i mean are
they the hottest team in football i
think they are right now they just
finished well these dealers the steelers
well yeah
but just like the last few weeks it just
yeah they're on fire
and and and they're so easily overlooked
because they've been so mediocre to bad
for so long
and and when have we seen them in a big
game in prime time i mean they're kind
of just like there
right yeah if you're watching the entire
league and following all 32 teams the
dolphins are kind of there they're
creating some intriguing highlights when
you watch the games they look pretty
damn good but they've yet to really
arrive we're waiting for that moment
when they declare themselves and they
they have to wait until week 17 for
another crack at the bills and
that may be our
yeah last sunday night of the season
game because uh it it could be for all
the marbles in the afc east but that may
be when we get to see tua and your boy
blue on the field at the same time chris
why haven't we seen more exotic looks
though for tua in his first few games i
think that they haven't felt the need to
you know i don't think that's right now
they're going wait we got a great
defense we're going to run the ball a
little bit
you know and then what does he do really
well we've talked about the bootlegs and
things like that
and oh it's one on one hey let's throw
an out route or a fade i i just think
they're that they're comfortable playing
that style of football and they'll
slowly start to indoctrinate them more
and more into
more and more offense and ideas and
schemes and things like that so
i i think they're playing a style of
football that really this is how brian
flores wants to play i don't think he
wanted to play
ryan fitzpatrick 47 times a game shotgun
maybe he throws four touchdowns maybe he
throws four interceptions this week we
don't know what fitzpatrick this is the
way i think it's a defensive coach and i
think he likes his style and then i mean
there's special teams too look what
they're doing i mean the special teams
won the game yesterday block punt one
yard touchdown oh the chargers jump off
sides on a fourth and short
and let miami get the first down they
score another touchdown i mean it's just
the chargers are unbelievable i've never
seen a team invent more ways to lose a
game on a week-to-week basis than them
but but i've always heard it it's like
four to six weeks of game film and then
defenses are ready yeah to take away
what the quarterback wants to do to
frustrate him to confuse him i mean i
keep waiting for that moment
when
that there's a specific game plan that's
designed
to address the things the dolphins are
trying to do with tua
to remove those to attack those and to
force something else the belichick
approach and whenever they play the
dolphins again maybe that's when it'll
happen chris but but i keep waiting for
that yeah and maybe it's maybe it's a
few weeks away well yeah and you know
again they're just they're not having to
be over reliant on him you know that's
that's the big thing too you know the
though though defenses are gonna figure
out i mean yesterday you saw it wasn't
beautiful it wasn't pretty
but they just did enough you know i
think they were all over some of the
bootlegs and things that they saw last
week out of to tua so yeah they're gonna
have to continue to you know counter
punch off of wait this is what we've
done but we got to infuse something new
to his attack here on a weekly basis to
give us that advantage but man you talk
about a team that plays three phases of
the game complete complimentary football
week after week it's three games in a
row where you've seen defense special
teams offense all work together and they
pull off upsets and and wins and they
look damn good
one guy i had to talk to yesterday was
ronald jones who had 192 yards rushing
98 of which came on
one play and i talked to him about
how he used the available technologies
who says technology isn't good the
available technologies at his disposable
or at his disposal as the case may be to
to avoid jeremy chin's effort to knock
him down
franchise record 98 yard touchdown how'd
your lungs feel on that run
yeah i'm not gonna lie with cold turkey
you know coming out of the half pound so
i felt good you know i was a lot of this
great job and uh just had to be one man
two men here
so uh yeah
how much did you use the video board to
see how close the guy was behind you
yeah i used it i probably looked up too
really you know uh she just put my head
down and run but it definitely gave me a
good sense of what it was
uh i thought you know he's about to go
for the legs so i had to you know give
him a little a little hurdle step and uh
it just felt good to get that you know
going like that
it really is neat to see when it's
happening that the guy has the presence
of mind to use that that video screen
which daniel jones
didn't use
when he
fell flat on his face a few weeks ago he
thought somebody was close to him you
could see he wasn't looking up chris if
he looks up he knows he's in the clear
he doesn't have to try to run faster
than his body will carry him ronald
jones used it knew exactly when to elude
jeremy chin and gets the 98 yard touch
yeah it's amazing i have no feel for
that situation in my life uh no point
was i running away from defenders for
touchdowns or looking up at a scoreboard
but i mean amazing and just amazing by
the bucks ronald jones and hey let's not
forget 98 yard touchdown run running
back got the ball in his hand he should
be slower i mean you got to be special
fast to have that kind of long touchdown
run in the nfl
yeah absolutely it was great to see
great to see the buccaneers turn it
around after what we saw last sunday
night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports